understandably enough our societies pay
vast attention to the idea of sexiness
far more questionably they tempt us to
believe that it might be easy to
understand what this quality consists of
the leading suggestion takes its
starting point from the biological
sciences we learned that sex aims at
successful reproduction and genetic
fitness in the coming generation
therefore sexiness must logically
comprise a host of semi-conscious
signals of fertility and of resistance
to disease bilateral facial symmetry
large bright pupils full lips youthful
skin and melanin rich hair but this
analysis to quickly assumes that it
might be simple to know what sex really
aims at unlike most other living beings
our biological drives sit alongside and
appoints take second place to a range of
emotional priorities chief among these
is the desire to overcome loneliness and
share our vulnerability within the arms
of a safe and intimate other we seek
through a physical act to overcome our
customary psychological alienation and a
host of painful barriers to being known
and accepted viewed through such a lens
the erotic is not so much a promise of
reproductive health as a suggestion of a
redemptive capacity for closeness
connection understanding and an end to
shame and isolation it is this emotional
mission that explains the conundrum
sometimes generated by people whom one
would expect by all standard biological
criteria to possess an exemplary sexual
aura but who managed to leave us cold
just as it may shed light on the
associated puzzle of those physically
more challenged candidates who
nevertheless lay claim to a rare power
far outstripping the quality of their
hair or the lustre of their eyes the
people whom we call sexy despite or
aside from the raw facts of their
appearance are those whose features and
manner suggest an unusual ability to
fulfill the underlying emotion
purpose of lovemaking the way they
respond to a joke the curve of an
eyebrow the characteristic motion of
their forehead the way of holding their
hands convey in and unconsciously
understood but hugely eloquent language
that one is in the presence of a kindly
being who is liable to understand our
broken and Confused aspects to help us
over our loneliness and submerge sadness
and reassure us of our basic legitimacy
in worth someone with whom we can at
last reduce our normal suspicions cast
aside our armor and feel safe playful
and accepted whatever the quality of
their skin or balance of their
proportions it is these aspects that
have a true power to excite us in a
melancholy and avoidant world this is
the real turn-on we hear so much about
what we might need to do to increase our
physical appeal but by getting more
detailed about the psychological traits
that drive desire we could learn to pay
as much if not more attention to the
foundations of an exciting mindset armed
with a broader understanding of the aims
of sexuality some of the following might
also henceforth deserve to be counted as
valuable sources of sexiness a sense of
being slightly at odds with mainstream
society whether at work with friends or
around family we're too often hemmed in
by exhausting requirements to fit in and
subscribe to dominant notions of what it
means to be good and acceptable
requirements which nevertheless leave
behind or censor a lot of our internal
reality there ends up being a lot we
mustn't say and even more we shouldn't
even really feel what a relief then to
note perhaps via a write which in
another's upper lip that we are in the
presence of someone who knows how to
adopt a gently skeptical perspective on
prevailing assumptions someone with whom
we'd be able to break away and express
doubts about revered ideas or people and
cast a cathartic lis skeptical gaze on
the normal rules of life good sex
promises to feel like something of a
conspiracy against everybody else an
unshockable nature the more we're honest
an exploratory about ourselves the more
we realize that there is much inside our
characters that might surprise or
horrify outsiders that we possess
alarming degrees of vulnerability
meanness strangeness waywardness and
folly our standard response may be shame
and embarrassment and yet we quietly
hunger to be properly witnessed and
accepted as we really are
what may prove supremely sexy therefore
are suggestions that another person has
explored their own deep ourselves with
courage has a handle on their darkness
and may on this basis be capable of
extending an uncensored perspective on
our own attention between good and bad
someone who paid no attention whatsoever
to decency and scoffed at all propriety
might be merely alarming yet what can
prove uniquely appealing is a person
alive both to duty and temptation to the
pull of maturity and the draw at least
for a little while in the early hours of
wickedness a divided person
simultaneously responsible and marked by
a touch of desperation vigor and
impatience in addition might come a
potential for aggression and anger that
they manage to keep very sane ly under
control in daily life but that they knew
how to release at points in private
someone whose capacity for a little
cruelty was all the more moving because
it stood out against a customary habit
of extreme consideration and gentleness
kindness a lot of our reality deserves
compassion and sympathy how compelling
therefore to come across someone whose
features would belie a willingness to
extend charity towards a lot that is
less than perfect in human nature
someone who could know how much we stand
in need of forgiveness and who could
laugh generously with and at us because
they knew how to do the same in relation
to themselves we've allowed our concern
for sexiness to be coarsened by physical
obsession because we are under the sway
of an overly simplistic biological sense
of what sex is aiming at yet
by recovering contact with some of what
we emotionally crave from another person
we can happily but not merely
conveniently rediscover that the real
turn-on is never just a well-polished
body but always and primordial II a well
fashioned soul great dates are made up
of great conversations our dating cards
are designed to spark insightful and
playful encounters click the link on
screen now to find out more
you